[Music]
I basically don't think that denial is
as big a problem as many in America do
and the data show now that seventy-three
percent of Americans believe global
warming is real and happening now
seventy percent of them are concerned
about it you can get an enormous amount
politically done if you have the support
of seventy percent of the country I
think those numbers those numbers are
also moving and solar grow over the
coming years for me the much bigger
problem is that even though Americans
are concerned about climate change
nobody wants to spend as much as ten
dollars a month
to address it the median commitment a
recent poll found was just one dollar a
month so while people are concerned
about climate change they're not
concerned enough and my personal
perspective is that the main goal for
climate action is to make those people
who are concerned but still
fundamentally complacent about the issue
to be really engaged in a way that they
prioritize climate change in their
politics and their voting and make sure
that our leaders think of climate change
is a first-order political priority not
a third or fourth order political
priority and maybe even a political
imperative that governs all others
because that is true if you care about
economic inequality if you care about
violence basically every political thing
that you could worry about in this world
bears the fingerprint of climate change
and will be made worse if climate change
continues unabated so addressing any of
them on some level means addressing
climate change and that's the
perspective I think we really need to
have or more of us need to have there is
a real concern about preaching to the
choir I don't think if that is being an
issue of people like me that is people
who were up until quite recently
you know aware of climate worried about
it but who didn't orient their lives
around it I think that there's a bigger
risk of advocates and activists talking
to one another and not addressing the
sort of median concerned liberal who is
worried but fundamentally complacent
that to me is the main target of
messaging and I when I look around the
world I see many many more people like
that many more societies like that then
I see people who are really deeply
committed or who are really deeply in
denial and I say that as someone who
felt that way myself until quite
and who was awakened from that
complacency by fear and alarm which is
one reason why I think that talking
bluntly about the science and everything
that it projects for our near-term
future is really important we shouldn't
shy away from the projections that
science has made for us we should look
as squarely at them as we can even if
they horrify us because fear can be
mobilizing can be motivating we know
that from environmental history we know
that from advocacy history in this case
I don't think it needs to be the only
way that we talk about climate change
but we shouldn't be scared too we
shouldn't be scared of fear we should
know that the impacts are terrifying and
that we need to do everything we can to
avoid as many of them as we can
[Music]